Hallo! Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt.
Heute gibt es mal eine etwas andere Pizza,
und zwar gibt’s heute eine Kreuzung der
italienischen Pizza und dem türkischen Lahmacun. Lahmacun kennt ihr vielleicht, das sind diese
ganz ganz dünnen, man sagt auch "türkische Pizza" dazu aber eigentlich hat es mit Pizza
nichts zu tun.
Jedenfalls werde ich heute wirklich eine türkische
pizza daraus machen.
Dafür mache ich jetzt erst mal einen Hefeteig.
Ich zeige euch mal die Zutaten.
Dafür nehme ich 700g Dinkelmehl, 200 g Hartweizengrieß,
einen halben Würfel Hefe, 30g Zuckerrübensirup,
500g warmes Wasser, 2TL Salz, etwas Pfeffer
und 6 Löffel Olivenöl.
Ich nehme jetzt erst mal die Hefe, statt einen
halben Würfel Hefe könnt ihr auch eine Päckchen
Trockenhefe nehmen.
Und ihr könnt den Hefeteig, also den Pizzateig,
wirklich super vorbereiten.
Auch gerne einen Tag vorher schon oder zwei
Tage vorher und dann im Kühlschrank lagern.
Und dann nehmt ihr aber auch die Hälfte der
Hefe.
Also wennn ihr den jetzt wirklich über den
Tag oder zwei Tage im Kühlschrank lagern
wollt einfach nochmal die Hefemenge reduzieren.
ich gebe jetzt hier noch den Zuckerrübensirup
dazu.
Statt Zuckerrübensirup könnt ihr z.B. auch
Zucker benutzen einfach ein bisschen.
Aber der Sirup bringt zum einen eine dunkle
Farbe mit rein und so ein bisschen einen malzigen
Geschmack.
jetzt gebe ich hier das Wasser dazu.
Und einfach kurz verrühren, damit sich die
Hefe auflöst.
Ihr könnt Hefe übrigens immer einfrieren.
Also ich hab auch immer eigentlich einen ganz
guten Hefevorrat da.
Immer auch etwas im Gefrierschrank und wenn
ich sie dann brauche, nehme ich sie einfach
raus und lass sie bei Raumtemperatur auftauen
oder im Kühschrank am Abend vorher.
dann habt ihr immer frische Hefe da, die finde
ich nämlich etwas besser als Trockenhefe.
okay, und jetzt kommen einfach alle anderen
Zutaten rein.
Ihr könnt den Teig, hups [verschüttet etwas
Mehl], natürlich auch mit der Hand verkneten.
So habe ich aber beide hände frei.
Hartweizengrieß nehme ich jetzt auch noch
mit rein, einfach für eine schöne Struktur.
den Salz noch mit rein und Pfeffer für den
Geschmack.
Musik
zum Schluss noch das Öl und dann kann der
Teig in 5 bis 10 Min. zu einem richtig schönen,
geschmeidigen Hefeteig verknetet werden.
Musik, [Öl wird hineingegossen und der Teig
geknetet]
der Teig sieht jetzt perfekt aus. ich habe
den jetzt auch schon mit Hitze geknetet, einfach
die Maschine auf 34 Grad eingestellt.
So ist er nämlich schon mal warm und kann
auch schön aufgehen.
ich nehme ihn jetzt kurz raus, und dann kurz
zu einer Kugel formen.
Und der hat auch schon eine ganz andere Haptik,
als so ein normaler Hefeteig mit nur Mehl.
Der ist so ein bisschen grober und das passt
später wirklich perfekt zu der türkischen Pizza
und jetzt fette ich einfach die Schüssel
ein bisschen, damit der Teig nicht anklebt
und fette den Teig auch mit Backtrennspray.
So trocknet die Oberfläche nicht aus. und
kann ihn jetzt abgedeckt für ne halbe Stunde
bis Stunde aufgehen lassen.
Bis er sich schön verdoppelt hat.
Und in der Zwischenzeit kann ich auch schon
die Füllung vorbereiten, das könnt ihr auch
schon am Tag vorher machen.
Dann habt ihr alles bereit, und könnt dann
wenn ihr essen möchtet alles einfach nur
noch zubereiten
okay, normalerweise würde ich ihn jetzt hier
aufgehen lassen, aber ich brauch die Maschine
jetzt für mein Hackfleisch.
Also lass ich den jetzt im Ofen aufgehen [Schaltet
die Maschine aus] und kann hier weiter  arbeiten.
Für die Hackfleischmasse brauche ich 700g
Hackfleisch, ich hab jetzt hier Rinderhackfleisch,
zwei Zwiebeln, zwei Knoblauchzehen, etwas
Olivenöl, Paprikamark, Wasser und hier noch
die Gewürze Salz, Pfeffer und Kreuzkümmel.
wenn ihr so richtig die Pizza türkisch Style
machen wollt, finde ich solltet ihr das Hackfleisch
halb halb mischen, das heißt, Lamm und Rind,
dann habt ihr den richtigen Lahmacungeschmack.
Ich hatte jetzt leider keins da und hab jetzt
deswegen nur Rinderhackfleisch, aber alles gut.
Ich nehm jetzt ein bisschen Olivenöl, geb es
hier in meine Pfanne und kann es erhitzen, und
da kann ich dann das Hackfleisch gleich schon
mal portionsweise anbraten.
und in der Zwischenzeit kann ich hier schon
mal die Zwiebeln und Knolauchzehen fein schneiden.
Und ich mach das hier getrennt von der Soße,
denn so habe ich die Möglichkeit einmal die
Hackfleischmasse zu machen, dann die Tomatensoße
extra zu machen und dann kann man es sogar
wenn man möchte auch vegan zubereiten, eben
ohne diese Hackfleischmasse und nimmt dann
anstatt Hackfleisch etwas Gemüse.
Pilze z.B. oder Zucchini. alles ganz fein
hacken und scharf anbraten und dann hab ich
hier auch was für den Volkan und den Dennis :-)
Musik,[hackt Zwiebeln]
jetzt einfach in kleinen Portionen anbraten
[brät das Fleisch an]
Also wenn ihr ne kleine Pfanne habt, dann
in mehreren Portionen, bei mir passt jetzt
auch die ganze Portion rein.
das is einfach damit das Hackfleisch nicht
kocht, sondern wirklich schön angebraten
wird ne.
Ansonsten kühlt die Pfanne schnell ab und
es köchelt dann eher vor sich hin.
und jetzt enfach schön krümelig anbraten,
ich geb da doch noch ein bisschen Öl dazu.
[brät das Fleisch an]
jetzt ist es hier schön krümelig angebraten,
und jetzt kann ich die Zwiebel- und Knoblauchwürfel
dazu geben.
Musik
Jetzt schön mit anbraten, das restiche Öl
auch mit dazu geben.
Und ich hab jetzt hier eine halbe Zwiebel
aufgehoben für die Tomatensoße, weil es
einfach zwei große Zwiebeln waren.
und jetzt hier schön mit anschwitzen,
so bekommt ihr einfach wirklich richtig schöne
Röstaromen mit ins Gericht
ich geb da jetzt auch mal kurz den Deckel
drauf, dass einfach die Knoblauch- und Zwiebelwürfel
schön glasig werden.
So für etwas zwei bis drei Minuten.
[Deckel kommt auf den Topf und wird wieder geöffnet]
Perfekt!
Hier kann ich jetzt das Paprikamark hinzugeben,
das passt geschmacklich wirklich super, weil
es einfach total würzig und herzhaft schmeckt
wenn ihr das nicht da habt, könnt ihr aber
auch Tomatenmark nehmen und dann einfach mit
etwas Paprikapulver nachwürzen.
dann lösche ich es jetzt mit dem Wasser ab.
So lösen sich jetzt auch alle Bestandteile
am Boden.
und jetzt einfach nur noch mit Salz und Pfeffer
würzen.
Kreuzkümmel dazu
wenn ich jetzt Lamm noch da hätte, hätte
ich noch ein Lorbeerblatt mit rein geschmmissen,
einfach so für den Geschmack.
Und dann ist die Hackfleischfüllung schon
mal fertig und ich mach jetzt gleich noch
die Tomatensoße.
Deckel drauf und Herd aus.
für die Tomatensoße nehme ich einen EL Olivenöl,
die halbe Zwiebel, etwas Tomatenmark und gestückelte
Tomaten aus der Dose.
hier habe ich ne Knoblauchzehe, Salz getrocknete
minze, Pfeffer und Chilli.
Drei grüne Spitzpaprika, die sind nicht scharf
und etwas Petersilie.
Für die Tomatensoße kann ich jetzt auch
das Olivenöln in einem kleinen Topf erhitzen
und die Zwiebelwürfel schon mal anbraten.
Da kommt auch gleich die Knoblauchzehe dazu.
[Knoblauchzehe wird gehackt]
das Ganze jetzt wieder schön glasig anbraten.
Und ich kann hier schon mal die Spitzpaprika
und die Petersilie fein schneiden.
Musik [Parika wird halbiert]
ich nehm hier das Innere einfach raus, dieses
Kerngehäuse.
Musik [Kerngehäuse wird entfernt]
So richtig schöne kleine Würfelschen schneiden
[Paprika wird gehackt]
und dann geb ich hier jetzt das Tomatenmark
dazu, brate es kurz an
Und dann direkt mit den Tomaten ablöschen.
Jetzt könnt ihr hier jetzt auch gleich die
Gewürze mit dazu geben.
Gwürze werden hinzugegeben
und einfach die Soße aufkochenn lassen.
[Stäbe der Petersilie werden weggeschnitten]
da schneid ich jetzt aber die Stäbe weg,
die schmeiße ich aber nicht weg, sondern
frier sie ein und wenn ich dann mal ne Gemüsebrühe
mach, dann hab ich sie einfach schon bereit.
Die stören jetzt auch hier in der Soße
die restliche Petersilie einfach schön fein
hacken.
Ein bisschen was hebe ich mir auf für später
zum Bestreuen
[Petersilie wird gehackt]
jetzt ist im Prinzip alles vorbereitet, die
Paprika kommt hier jetzt mit rein.
Das bringt so diesen Lahmacun geschmack mit
rein.
auch Petersilie, aber wie gesagt, nicht alles.
Den Rest bewahr ich mir auf für zum Drüberstreuen
Jetzt hab ich die Soße fertig, das Hackfleisch
ist fertig.
Warte jetzt einfach nur noch bis der Teig
schön aufgeht
Und dann können wir die Pizza gleich zubereiten
und das könnt ihr alles wirklich super vorbereiten.
Den Teig könnt ihr vorbereiten, Hackfleisch,
die Soße.
Auch gerne alles schon am Vortag / oder am Vorabend.
und dann wenn ihr essen, möchtet einfach
frisch alles zusammensetzen.
Und dann habt ihr wirklich ganz schnell und
einfach ein schönes Abendessen oder ein schönes
Iftaressen, wenn ihr Fastenbrechen macht.
Und habt eben am Abend nicht so viel Arbeit.
Also los geht’s. Ich nehme jetzt ein bisschen
Hartweizengrieß hier auf meine Backmatte.
ihr könnt auch Mehl nehmen, aber Hartwezengrieß
hat einfach ein bisschen mehr Biss
und ihr könnt jetzt entweder vier Große
machen oder z.B.
Zwölf kleine oder auch 16 kleine Pizzen
ich mach jetzt 12.
ich nehm jetzt einfach hier einen Einteiler.
Dann hab ich nämlich schon 12.
Ansonsten vierteln und dann nochmal jedes
Viertel dritteln.
[Teilt den Teig auf]
jetzt hier so kleine Kugeln formen
[Formt Teigkugeln]
okay.
Die decke ich jetzt schön ab, damit sie nicht
trocknen.
Und nehme jetzt nochmal ein bisschen Gries.
jetzt nehme ich hier meine erste Kugel.
Jetzt könnt ihr sie einfach mit der Hand
öffnen, wie so ein Pizzateig oder ihr nehmt
ein Ausrollstab.
die sind tatsächlich so klein, ich glaub ich
mach das mim Ausrollstab.
da passt meine Hand gleich nicht rein.
[rollt dein Teig aus.]
jetzt habe ich die hier schon geöffnet.
Ich mach jetzt erst mal nur zwei fertig, damit
ihr gleich seht wie das funktioniert und später
mach ich für die Meute alles fertig.
ich nehm jetzt hier einfach mein lochblech,
ihr könnt aber auch das Emaille Pizzablech
nehmen.
das fette ich jetzt ganz leicht mit Backtrennspray
[fettet das blech]
Pizzastufe ist auch schon an im Backofen,
ansonsten nehmt ihr einfach Unterhitze, wenns
geht, die höchste Einstellung 250 G. z.B.,
damit die Pizza schön von unten kross wird.
und jetzt kann ich sie auch schon belegen.
mach ich aber jetzt direkt hier drauf.
Und nachdem Belegen auch wirklich sofort backen.
Ansonsten habt ihr nämlich das Problem, gerade
bei so einem großlöchrigen Blech, dass der
Pizzateig hinuntersinkt und dann kriegt ihr
die Pizza nicht mehr ab.
also wirklich belegen und sofort in den Backofen
rein.
[Pizza wird bestrichen]
ja, also schön Tomatensoße verteilen.
dann die Hackfleischmasse.
Und wenn ihr wollt, könnt ihr noch Pinienkerne
drüber streuen.
Die rösten dann auch noch schön im Backofen.
pefekt, und so kommts schon mal in den Backofen
bis ich dann die anderen mache
Musik, [pizza kommt in den Ofen]
ich hab mich jetzt doch en-
[wird unterbrchen] was machsch du jetzt hier?
Egal.
Iss enfach die Petersilienstängel. [lacht]
Murat: ich bin wieder weg, tschüss.
ich hab mich jetzt doch dazu entschlossen
sech große zu machen, klar die ersten zwei
kleinen die lass ich jetzt, aus dem Rest mach
ich jetzt vier Große, bzw. mittelgroße,
denn es gefällt mir einfach optisch besser
und ich möchte, dass es eher luftiger wird
und nicht ganz so dünn.
deswegen nehme ich jetzt das Emailleblech und
fette das kurz.
und da gibt es nämlich nen richtig coolen
Trick
also auch wieder hier erst mal mit etwas Hartweizengrieß
für den Crunchboden.
dann ein bisschen ausrollen.
wenn die Teigkugeln länger liegen, dann könnt
ihr euch wirklich den Ausrollstab sparen,
dann ist der Teig einfach elastischer.
und ihr könnt ihn direkt mit der Hand öffnen.
und hier mach ich es nämlich so
ich nehm noch ein bisschen Gries mit aufs
Blech rüber und kann jetzt praktisch durch
ne Drehbewegung den Teig einfach im Blech
öffnen.
Ich form hier nämlich immer gerne so einen
kleinen Rand hier.
Und dann ganz normal belegen wie vorhin eben
auch.
Musik, [Pizza wird belegt]
in so nem Emaille blech könnt ihr sie nämlich
auch zubereiten, alles vorbereiten und dann
nach und nach backen.
Sally zu Samira: ne, da muss man nicht warten
Samira: ja.
Sally: und nicht sofort backen
[Pizza wird in den Ofen geschoben]
[Bilder der fertigen Pizza werden gezeigt]
Sally: meine Testperson ist jetzt da
Murat: ja, ich bin eine glückliche Testperson.
Sally: die anderen Pizzen sind noch im Ofen,
teilweise aber auch schon fertig.
Gleich wird nämlch bei unsgegessen.
Ihr könnt jetzt wie gesagt noch die Petersilie streuen.
Sally: ich bin echt gespannt.
Ich hab jetzt die übrigens zubereitet, und
das finde ich wirklich besser, zubereitet
ein bisschen liegen lassen,so kann der Teig
nochmal schon luftig aufgehen.
Sally: und die die ich direkt gebacken habe,
ist halt flacher und knuspriger.
Murat: und das ist jetzt eine richtige Pizza-
[Sally unterbricht: Lahmacun Style.]
Murat: Lahmacun Style, also kein Lahmacun
sondern richtig :-)
[sally gleichzeitig: Italien trifft Türkei.
Murat: ja
Sally: guck mal, jetzt nehmm ich noch Jogurt,
3,5%-igen, etwas Salz
Murat: und das ist jetzt natürlich auch
wieder typisch Türkisch.
Man isst jetzt viel viel mit Jogurt zusammen,
Sally gleichzeitig: alles mit yogurt.
Minze.
Murat: Minze und ein bisschen Knoblauch, hast
du noch?
Sally: ne aber ich hab genug Knoblauch drin.
Murat: Achso... hast du knoblauch?
Okay.
Sally: ja, deswegen essen jetzt auch alle
mit, denn sonsst haben wir auch keine Freunde
mehr.
Murat: ja
Sally: äh Pfeffer brauch ich noch, wo hab
ich den Pfeffer?
Hier.
Murat: Knoblauch hilft gegen alles, das ist
bewiesen, das sorgt dafür dass ihr den Mindestabstand
einhaltet.
Von 1,5 metern.
Sally: Hallo?
Und jetzt kann ich das hier zuschneiden.
Ela aus dem Hintergrund: Mama, ich hab alle anderen gerufen,
Sally: hast du alle gerufen?
Ela: dürfen die rein?
Sally: ja, die dürfen alle rein
Sally: so jetzt probieren wir mal.
Magst du erst mal ohne Jogurt probieren?
Murat: erst mal ohne Jogurt, genau dass es
den geschmack nich so arg verfälscht.
Sally: ich bin eher der Jogurt esser.
Sally: und ich bin mal gespannt, ich hab heute was neues gemacht, ob du das merkst, am Pizzateig.
Murat: boah.
Ela schreit : können sie jetzt rein Mama.
Sally:und ich hab nicht so viel Chilli.
Sally: ja die können alle rein schon, und
ich hab nicht so viel chilli wegen den kindern.
Wie kann man mit zwei Bissen, ganz hrlich
eine Stück Pizza aufessen?
Ela: mama, können die aneren schon mal an
den Tisch gehen?
Sally: die können schon mal an den Tisch
gehen ja.
Murat: das ist mit abstand einer der besten
Pizzen, die ich jemals gegessen hab.
Sally: echt?
Murat: ohne Spaß, wahnsinn.
Sally: Magsch noch ein Stück mit Jogurt?
Sally: und wie gesagt, ihr könnt einfach
alles wunderbar vorbereiten, den Pizzateig,
die Tomatensoße, das Hackfleisch.
Dann könnt ihr es schön vorbereiten und
wirklich kurz vorm essen alles in den Backofen
schieben und fertig.
"Murat: Hammer.
Sally: gut?
Murat: mhm
Sally: und ich hab noch, warte warte die anderen,
wir essen gleich am tisch.
Murat: ja tut mir leid.
Sally"
"und ich hab dazu noch nen gemischten Salat
gemacht, mit Rotkohl, mit Karotten, da steht
auch jeder drauf, mit Spinat.
Murat: macht die pizza bitte nach.
Das ist wirklich der absolute Hammer.
Sally: mir läuft auch schon das Wasser im Mund zusammen,
Murat: vielleicht die beste Pizza die ihr
jemals gegessen habt.
Sally: ja, guten Appetit.
Afiyet olsu, das Rezept gibt es natürlich
in meiner App.
Zum Nachlesen zum Hoch- und Runterrechnen.
und wir essn jetzt auch.
Tschüüssi.
Murat: Komm Ela das schmeckt so lecker. boah hey wenn ihr das probiert, das ist
voll der kracher wirklich
Sally: hallo?
Können wir am Tisch essen?
Geht’s noch?